the U.S Secretary of State on what he
says is a mission to open lines of
communication between Washington and
Beijing Anthony blinken met foreign
minister qingang for talks and a working
dinner on Sunday the highest ranking U.S
official to visit in five years
blinken's trip follows concerns that
mounting tensions between the two sides
could spiral into conflict
in recent weeks Washington has accused
the people's operation Army of unsafe
Maneuvers by military jets and warships
in the South China Sea
China cut military Communications with
the U.S after former house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi visited Taiwan in August China
considers the self-ruled Island Chinese
territory and opposes any official
contact between Washington and Taipei
the Chinese are also protesting U.S
sanctions imposed on defense minister
Lee Xiang Fu following the purchase of
Russian weapons in 2018. another point
of contention restrictions on Chinese
technology companies due to security and
human rights concerns concerns Beijing
has dismissed as attempts to contain
Chinese progress and economic growth the
problem from the Chinese side is that
they see these words as not being fully
backed up with actions right so on the
one hand you've got these kind of
positive signals from the president and
a number of senior officials on the
other hand the U.S still appears to be
kind of marshaling its allies to to to
stymie China to cut it off from Key
technology in turn China has tightened
its own National Security launching
investigations into several U.S
consultancy firms and banning sales of
the U.S chip company Micron Lincoln's
visit was initially planned for February
but postponed after the shooting down of
a suspected Chinese spy balloon
expectations are low for any
breakthrough their analysts say some
dialogue is better than none despite
deep distrust on both sides it's hoped
Lincoln's visit will pave the way for
more high-level meetings and a meeting
between President Xi Jinping and Joe
Biden later this year they last met in
November on the sidelines of the G20
Summit in Indonesia but before another
is planned Beijing will look for
assurances that Washington is committed
to putting relations back on track as
the Chinese describe it and respecting
what they say are China's core interests
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing